- Tattoo artist Kat Von D is in hot water
for potentially stealing
someone's photograph
to use it in a tattoo.
This has a lot of people confused.
It seems like a tattoo
is a transformative work.
And how is that like
the actual photograph?
Well, first of all,
photographs can obviously be copyrighted,
and the fact that it's transformative
isn't really the issue.
That actually might
hurt more than it helps.
Just because you've changed the medium
and taken it from a photograph
and turned it into a tattoo
doesn't mean that you haven't committed
copyright infringement.
In fact, that's probably
a derivative work.
Imagine if you took a
book like "Jurassic Park"
and turned it into the
movie "Jurassic Park."
You've changed the medium,
but you're still infringing
on the copyright.
And fair use probably doesn't apply
because you're not changing the purpose
of the original photograph,
it's still being viewed for,
effectively, entertainment.
So Kat Von D could be in hot water
and liable for hundreds
of thousands of dollars
under statutory damages.
Which is why she should
really watch this channel
because if you don't,
I'll see you in court.